let's go back to the writing process
with you and Melissa so what was going
on in your life when you started coming
up with ideas for all I want I know it's
her ideas for the story initially right
yeah yeah she she I was in the middle of
finishing a full-length play and I was
in the middle of work shopping that play
because there was a story in that that I
wanted to work out you know was doing
that and so you know when she first
approached me and my mind was really in
in in another story in terms of you know
my writing you know and as an actor I
really was kind of taking myself out of
the things a little bit because I just
first of whatever reason just gotten
kind of disenchanted with with the
process of of an actor's life you know
so I started really was writing
something to produce and direct and when
she approached me there was something
about the story that you know both both
Melissa and I are big fans of ensemble
movies and so that was our initial kind
of connection where were fans of
ensemble films and I also think that the
theme of what we're trying to talk about
in this movie is a really important
theme for me and for her this idea of
you know people in the modern American
city right now I feel like at least
certainly in Los Angeles you know
there's this kind of undercurrent of
stress and anxiety
absolutely and depression that people
don't talk about you see it yeah feeling
it you feel it you bump up against it
yeah and I'm not necessarily talking
about clinical disorders of anxiety or
depression or things like that
I'm talking about the garden-variety
kind of you know garden-variety kind of
weight of
of anxiety of stress of depression and
that is for me it feels like is a very
uh thought about you know area of modern
life you know people who are trying to
figure out what kind of jobs you know
they want to have do they want to switch
careers do they want to get married and
have kids do they are they happy with
their partner with with their you know
families and I think fee matically that
was something that we both wanted to
kind of you know pull apart and examine
and I think that's the wonderful thing
about this film is that it's got amazing
performances you know across the board
there's amazing technical kind of you
know prowess in terms of cinematography
and editing and composition I'm
certainly proud of my work as director
and Melissa and I are very proud of it
as producing partners and someone who
can have collaborated to make the script
happen but thematically I think it's an
interesting thing to talk about for the
audience that we don't already talk
about right now right I know there is a
taboo because people want to just make
it no nobody wants to get too heavy
about anything but I sense it and living
in LA as long as I have I've seen the
change and I don't know if it's just
because it's busier here but on a side
note and we can take this out if you if
you don't want to talk about it but
where you live and I won't say where it
is but it's removed in the Hollywood
Hills well it will it's removed from
Hollywood and you have a lovely place
here by the way and I can see why you
would want to be here
because it's not part of the industry
but you are so creative and you do
produce things you don't just talk about
them you have a body of work
why choose someplace that's not in the
heart of the industry well it was
initially by choice you know it was it
was based on so many different factors
in terms of where you want to put
yourself what do you want to make your
nest per say a lot oftentimes when you
don't have all the resources that you
want to
you know but I think as a result of all
these different factors forcing me to
make a decision I'm able to kind of have
a home that feels a little bit kind of
you know on the outskirts of the hub of
you know Hollywood and I think that
gives me a certain sense of I don't know
whether it's distance or peace from it
or whatever you know having having some
quiet time you know to to work on
whatever you want to work on so so you
don't feel that pull to be in sort of
the hub where there's all this no no no
no I mean not anymore I think when I
first moved down to LA it was really
important for me to kind of be
surrounded by you know what everything
is happening you know and that was
exciting for many years and I think now
it's kind of nice to sort of like be
around that have access to that but then
also be a way you know have the ability
to kind of like tuck yourself away and
and then not be surrounded by that are
you more creative in the daytime or a
nighttime
definitely in the daytime yeah I think
so I'm more of a morning morning person
and I think that's I don't know whether
melissa has ever complained about it I
don't think so but every time we would
have meetings I would always be like
let's do it
8:00 in the morning you know and she was
like yeah sure you know I think that's
also kind of interesting too because you
know I'm as a sidenote I'm collaborating
under the project with someone else
who's a night person you know and and
and that's like in some interesting ways
that's kind of caused some you know
friction because I'm like you know after
8:00 at 8:00 p.m. you know my mind sort
of just relaxes and it starts to think
about other things you know and and I
kind of want to eat and I kind of want
to watch a movie I kind of want to just
you know maybe go to the gym and and do
nothing
yeah
and during the day I'm really productive
and and for for this other person it's
the opposite interesting yeah I don't
know what it would be interesting to
take a tally to see you know where
people are they morning or they night
person you know and also their
collaborators are they are they the same
or opposite what about you are you a
morning creative person or you I would
say I get much more done after a cup of
coffee and in the morning and then past
a certain point you just I'm just done
and I I don't nothing is worse than
being behind a computer when it's like
2:00 a.m. right and I can't see straight
and I don't that's not where I'm my best
self lies right so I I get that but I
know there's some people that come alive
at night yeah and I just think we're
just hardwired differently and yeah that
there's no right way I mean you hear
these entrepreneurs that get up at like
4:45 and they take a cold shower and
their was ready and they're doing their
you know wheatgrass smoothie and that's
great I don't think I can do 4:45 but
everybody has really process but then
there's some people that fool themselves
and that's the trick I worry about I I
think I I definitely think that that
that the footnote to that question is is
really like you know when when do your
inspirations kind of come and for me
they come all over the place and any
time but oddly it comes at night you
know comes a night often as well I just
think that you let it sit you know
inspiration comes to you ideas you know
come to you and you sort of let it let
it sit around in your head you know and
and and and you can't really actively do
anything about ease for me I you know I
just sort of let it sit and then I will
actually try to you know execute on the
idea during the day you know did you
grow up in the big city
I grew up in the suburbs of the San
Francisco Bay Area you know I mean
worked and played in the city but who
suburbia you know but now la you know I
mean I mean la is unique in some ways
you know in a sense that there's so many
kind of like ambitious people coming
here to do what seems to me like an
impossible kind of task of making your
living as an artist you know and so I
think maybe with that maybe with you
know where the country is or whatever
you know or expectations or all these
kinds of different things cause anxiety
in the city you know cause anxiety in
people who are kind of expected to get
married or expected to make a certain
amount of money and their jobs are
expected to do certain things and and
and how that bumps up against you know
what they are able to do I think the
money part yeah this is a huge factor in
the city yeah being able to afford you
know where to live and and it's tough
you know
you know I mean it's it's it's it's a
really kind of and which is why I think
you know for me I wanted to really kind
of explore that in this movie because
this movie is very much about friendship
it's about family it's about love modern
love and life and all those kinds of
things and there's a lot of humor in
this story there's a lot of fun moments
in the story that I think the audience
can really kind of like enjoy they can
see themselves and their friends and
their family in the characters in this
movie but I think at the same time it
also starts a conversation about that
you know about anxiety
you